das jägerbataillon steiermark führt im
rahmen einer übung mit milizsoldaten
personen und kfz kontrollen und
unterstützt im fall des falles die
evakuierung der besucher
ich bin bürokaufmann im zivilberuf und
es ist eine herausforderung aus neuburg
entfliehen zu können und hier neue
tätigkeiten durchzuführen
ich arbeite für eine
videoproduktionsfirma und ich habe man
zuerst gar nicht vorstellen können was
genau unsere aufgaben hier bei der
airpower sein werden aber durchaus eine
sehr interessante aufgabe eine
schwierige aufgabe aber durchaus lösbar
zu sein
ich bin aus landsmann darüber auf der
welt eingesetzt und habe mit schwierigen
bedingungen zu tun und die erbauer sowie
eigentlich willkommene abwechslung